all right thanks for joining us at noon
i'm bianca holman
a high profile visit from the u.s
agriculture secretary's office here in
southern nevada
officials are checking out how summer
feeding programs are working
in local schools here hector mejia is
live with more
hey there well secretary vilsack is
making stops at a number of communities
across the country today it was
henderson's turn here at mcdonald
elementary
where that tour happened during lunch
service and we've learned
one in four students here in clark
county are food insecure meaning
they don't often know where their next
meal will come from
u.s agriculture secretary tom vilsack
said the american rescue plan
created a summer feeding program but
it's only
for a year and there's now push to make
it a permanent program
so today he met with governor steve
sisilak along with u.s
congresswoman susie lee they went over
the biden administration's goal to
promote healthy eating
and how the american family's plan will
help achieve that goal
it is an issue of food security it is
also an issue of nutrition
and what we saw today here at mcdonald's
school
is a commitment to both making sure that
youngsters are fed even during a
pandemic
millions of meals but also making sure
that they're fed well
the carrots the apple slices
good snacks quality snacks for
youngsters
here in clark county as many as three
out of four students
qualify for free or reduced lunches and
the secretary also talked about the
president's
infrastructure plan and how they're
working to pass a bipartisan package
to get the economy moving faster we are
in henderson this afternoon hector mejia
8 news now